傳說中有這樣一種人他特別善於控制別人的思想只要你盯著他的眼睛你就會無條件地信任他喜歡他相信他說的每一個字
伊麗莎白‧霍姆斯她就有這麼一雙大大的藍眼睛真誠的眼神一眨不眨地瞪著你僅僅30出頭她就瞪出來了市值百億的公司瞪出來了50億的身價瞪成了全美甚至全世界最炙手可熱的女企業家她的公司 Theranos一度是硅谷最亮眼的一顆星很有可能把世界的醫療體系都帶上一個新的高度
然而，自殺、誤診、威脅、監控，卻成了多少人揮之不去的噩夢。這個霍姆斯，他就像一個強大的巫師，一步一步催眠了他800多名員工，催眠了他的世紀夢幻董事會，催眠了媒體，催眠了全世界，也催眠了他自己。這個可以算得上是全世界最美的女騙子，帶著所有人進入了她一滴血的騙局。
1984年2月小霍姆斯出生在美國華盛頓一個非常富裕的家庭他爸之前是安然的副總裁沒錯就是我們之前講過的那個騙子公司安然霍姆斯從一生下來眼睛就特別大見誰都是一副天真無邪的樣子就直勾勾的盯著你所以我們就給他起個名字叫鄧姐
2002年18歲的鄧姐就進入到了世界名校斯坦福大學大一暑假鄧姐就去實習就接觸到了驗血當時她就萌生了一個想法你說每天給那病人抽一大管子血多費勁我要是就那一滴血就能驗出來這些人的疾病這將是一個多麼厲害的idea於是回到斯坦福鄧姐除了看書學習思考她還順帶著申請了一個專利可以實時測試血液而且可以穿戴非常的厲害這個想法真的是太好了
以咱們的美貌和才華，我可不能把時間都浪費在讀書上。於是，追隨著喬夫斯、比爾蓋茨、扎克伯格等等的矽谷大佬，霍姆斯，不對，鄧姐也從斯坦福輟學了。她用自己的學費建立了 Theranos,這個十年後將被全世界人記住的名字。而當時的鄧姐只有19歲。
聽了這個開頭是不是就感覺又來了一個天才的故事不可否認鄧姐的確是個天才但是她所有天才的技能裡面非常突出的一項就是蠱惑人心
鄧姐剛有這個想法的時候，她就去找了醫學院的一個教授，激情澎湃地闡述自己的想法。只可惜，這個教授自然是非常懂行的，他就苦口婆心地勸這個鄧姐，哎，孩子，你這想法是非常好，但是它理論上其實不太可能實現。但是鄧姐她就偏偏不信這個邪，於是她又找到了斯坦福工程學院的大院長陳寧·羅伯森，第一次就開始使用了他這項蠱惑人心的技能。
院長大人一直以來我們每次抽血都要用一個那麼長的針管戳進你的胳膊裡抽出來那麼大一管血要交那麼多錢然後等上兩三天才能拿到結果這是多麼令人害怕令人畏懼不是嗎
但是，倘若我有這樣一個機器，你只要到你們家樓下的超市、藥店，只要從指尖抽出那麼一滴血，花上幾十塊錢，只要幾個小時，就能檢測出很多需要的健康指標。沒有可怕的針頭，沒有漫長的等待，沒有高昂的費用。有的只是人們臉上洋溢的笑臉，那將是多麼美好。這就是我要做的事情。我要改變世界。I'm gonna change the world.
鄧姐就是這樣動之以情，笑之以情。錢寧教授被她說得熱血沸騰，孩子你就放心大膽的去幹吧。這個大院長成為了 Theranos 的第一名董事會成員，並且給鄧姐介紹了特別多的資源和投資人，還多次表示鄧姐就是一個天才。啊，第一位大佬，成功搞定。你說有了斯坦福院長的支持，那 Theranos 的融資之路那是相當順利，一年之內輕鬆融到了 600 萬美金的初始資金。
鄧姐的這個想法雖然很好但是現實很骨感它面臨著兩大問題第一個呢就是散熱問題你說這每個組件和零件都得散熱吧那這之間就會相互影響肯定有測不準
第二個呢，就是血量問題。你說他就抽那麼一滴血，然後要做那麼多測試，這在當前甚至都不存在理論上的可能。面臨著這麼兩座大山，鄧姐她肯定是需要一個顛覆級的理論，才能有那麼一丟丟的可能改變世界。但是她有野心，a lot of野心。我們知道硅谷圈一直流傳著一個這樣的精神，叫fake it until you make it,就是偽造它直到你做到它。
意思就是說牛皮咱先得吹出去有人信了就給你投錢然後你再趕緊去搞這樣才能有最快的發展你要是安不就班把什麼都弄出來再去找錢那別人早就有傑族先登了鄧姐自然是深諳此理論牛皮吹的是賊小你要找到你真正熱愛的東西就像愛迪生一樣這就是我們要研究的第一代驗血原型機我們就給它起名字叫愛迪生因為我們要改變世界
怎麼樣是不是聽著熱血沸騰我跟你說鄧姐這個蠱惑人心的能力可真不是蓋案全公司的人都被她忽悠的充滿鬥志這時候你問所有跟她接觸過的公司高管投資人那評價都是極其正面真誠聰明勇敢努力大家都認為眼前這個瞪著大眼睛的女孩將會改變世界
而且那時候正值歸股像Facebook、Twitter、LinkedIn這些新興的膨脹期但誰也不想錯過下一個扎克伯格經鄧姐這麼籌儲滿之的一忽悠那還不就是屁點屁點的把錢送來了在公司成立的7年中Theranos沒有網站沒有產品只有鄧姐那一雙大眼睛但就憑著這個融資將近1億美金並且一路招攬了各式高精尖端的醫療人才好 fake it我們做到了現在就要make it
鄧姐當然是不遺餘力的開始給她的技術團隊施壓。但凡有人質疑說這個東西不可能，物理法則不允許。哈哈，不好意思，那是你沒有硅谷精神。我們需要的是改變世界的人。We're gonna change the world.你不適合這裡。那你想想，這樣最後留下來的人都是不敢說真話的人罷了。Fake it until you make it這個精神放在一個醫療公司，那可是面臨著時大時的技術難題和真正的病人。你要是搞這套哲學，那就會產生非常可怕的後果。
2010年開始Theranos已經成立了7年了那時候他們連個原型機都還沒造出來鄧姐就已經開始迫不及待地向各大公司去兜售她的神奇的愛迪生驗血機了面對如此有吸引力的概念和如此能蠱惑人心的鄧姐你說哪個客戶願意錯過這樣的機會美國的連鎖藥店巨頭Walgreens和Safeway就紛紛向鄧姐拋來了橄欖枝他們的高管甚至連Theranos的實驗室都沒去過也根本就沒看著愛迪生的原型機就憑著簡簡單單的幾個報告和鄧姐的一張嘴和兩隻眼睛就相信了她
簽了戰略合作協議並且給他塞了1.05億美金作為貸款和投資
鄧姐該拿的錢全都拿到了但是就是死活也研究不出來她那改變世界的愛迪生驗血機為了通過一些檢查和測試鄧姐自己也知道那一滴血根本測不出來那麼多數據那鄧姐也著急啊怎麼辦呢只能子承父也不得不走上數據造假的老路他們就挑那些特別少數準確的數據才敢往報告裡頭寫
一旦有客人或者投資人要去他們的實驗室參觀的時候鄧姐就把他們帶過去先拉到實驗室給你抽那麼一滴血然後就帶著這個客人去參觀他們非常人性化的餐廳辦公室與此同時研發團隊就從後面拿出來了一臺西門子驗血劑把這個客人的血放進去給驗一個小時之後參觀完了客人回來了結果出來了客戶就拍手叫絕
甚至有一次拜登前去參訪鄧姐還大張旗鼓的造了一個假實驗室來糊弄這個未來的美國總統拜登看完了也非常高興啊就說這是我們技術的未來時間就這麼一點一點的流逝鄧姐還是沒研究出來她的愛迪生2013年4月整整三年了你要再不搭出點東西來剛才合作的公司Walgreens那就得翻臉了迫於現金和各方面的壓力鄧姐被迫選擇了全面上線
哪我就納悶了他連個產品都沒有他怎麼上線他怎麼敢上線鄧姐說了機器我現在還在造但是血我已經可以驗了只要一滴血哦他們拿到血樣後鄧姐就故技重施先拿西門子那個機器撿出來大概一半的指標但是好像這第三方的機器是不可能用一滴血去驗的樣本數量不夠怎麼辦呢鄧姐又來了一個損招就是稀釋說白了就是兌水
你想想這是嚴重違反檢測規定的那測出來的結果肯定都差的離譜這要放個一般的產品那頂多就是個偷空減料的問題但是在驗血的背後每一瓶血都是一個生命很多健康的人就莫名其妙的檢測出來糖尿病高血壓肺結核等等可怕的疾病而一個有梅毒的人竟然有超過30%的概率是測不出來的你就說說如果醫生要依賴這樣的結果去給病人看病那將是多麼的可怕事實上總共有超過17萬人用過theranos去驗血
不過由於Serenos開的網點並不多雖然有一些醫生和病人抱怨但是放在鄧姐的蠱惑能力和資本的助推下不值一提好忽悠完了團隊忽悠完了客戶現在又忽悠到了藥店連鎖巨頭的合作那接下來鄧姐就要開始忽悠全世界了
鄧姐心裡其實非常清楚她這個ID生機什麼也幹不了所以她需要更多的資金但是她也知道要找那種大型的私募或是風險投資機構自己也撈不著好萬一人家做背景調查的時候再查出來點什麼亂七八糟的東西那就全徹底玩完所以鄧姐非常明確她的融資目標就是那些成功過的男性長者
成功過的男性長者一般有什麼特點呢自信心爆棚憑感覺做判斷有錢而且喜歡漂亮小姑娘他首先找到了90多歲的前美國國務卿喬治·舒爾茨瞪著他的大眼睛我要讓這個世界充滿笑點我要改變這個世界I will change the world前國務卿一聽啊好孩子錢拿去鄧姐又找到了媒體大亨莫多克I'm gonna change the world好孩子1.25億美金拿去找到了沃爾瑪兄弟我要改變1.25億美金拿去就這樣
鄧姐成功籠到了7億美金公司估值達到了90億美金自己的身價也達到了45億美金而這些成功的男性長者中的一部分也成為了鄧姐的夢幻董事會這裡麵包括前美國國務卿前美國國防部長兩個前美國參議員前美國海軍上將前美軍陸戰隊將軍前富國銀行主席等等
你就說 戴爾諾的啥時候要開個董事會我估計這美國總統都得讓道投資人妥妥的搞定我們再來看看媒體這家好傢伙 這可是足足的噱頭顛覆性的概念美好的目標傳奇的創業故事夢幻般的董事會再加上鄧姐那大大的眼睛和年輕美貌的外表就吸引了無數知名的媒體大家都爭相來報導這個即將改寫未來的女企業家
鄧姐就開始登上各大主流媒體的封面參加各種名流晚宴入選2015年時代雜誌全世界最具影響力人物奧巴馬任命鄧姐為全球企業家協會美國大使人們開始把她跟比爾蓋茨喬布斯相提並論其實鄧姐一直就是喬布斯的一個小粉絲以至於她已經開始學喬布斯穿那種高領的黑色帽衣
營銷團隊也是直接就僱用蘋果之前用過的營銷公司，意圖就把自己打造成一個女版的喬布斯。當然為了讓她自己看著更加的沉穩可信，不知道從什麼時候開始，她說話的聲音就變得非常的低沉，甚至都讓人覺得有一點瘮人，就像這樣說話。
現在全世界都知道伊麗莎白·霍姆斯即將改變世界
你看鄧姐這個騙局和我們之前說到的麥道夫安然可不一樣她這邊可不是光幾個人知道就能行騙的她的整個科研團隊對她做的這一套都心知肚明所以整個研發團隊每天也都過得非常的煎熬因為他們知道鄧姐對外的這些承諾其實完全都做不到所以鄧姐就不得不用一套非常強硬的手段來防止自家的後院起火
首先入職的時候甭管你是什麼崗位都要簽一大厚厚的保密協議基本意思是你要敢說出任何關於公司的任何秘密我要讓你身敗名裂這不光是說員工對外就公司的部門和部門之間甚至同一個部門裡面不同的組之間都不能透露任何信息這就讓Fairnals這個公司尤其是研發團隊部門裡每天就是一種非常詭異的氛圍大家就跟要去當間諜一樣你有自己的街頭人至於剩下的人你最好什麼也別說
鄧姐自己也是非常的心虛她知道自己得罪了那麼多人於是給自己設置了一個20多人的安保團隊還把辦公室都加上防彈玻璃
但最重要的他需要一個非常強大的律師團隊他就僱了讓人聞風喪膽的這個大名鼎鼎的律師——達維‧博伊斯這個人曾經就代表美國的司法部把微軟告得體無完膚只要哪個員工一旦發現稍微有那麼一點問題達維‧博伊斯就會出面威逼理由把這事擺平實際上鄧姐融資融到的9億美金裡頭將近三分之一都花在了律師團隊的費用上Thernos的一個科學家甚至因為受到魔鬼律師的威脅而又不想做偽證而選擇了自殺
你說為了達到目標這時候鄧姐已經完全被自己所謂的理想蠱惑了這時候她雖然外表上光鮮亮麗獲得榮譽無數但她的內心是無比的絕望她只能靠輿論來給自己爭取時間爭取資金即使有最嚴格的內部監控最強大的董事會最廣泛的輿論支持也支撐不了多久就會有人開始起疑而一旦開了這個口那所有人就會群起而困之
2015年這時候鄧姐如日中天的時候在一個秘密線人的舉報下一名華爾街日報的記者John Carroll就開始對鄧姐的公司進行調查其實這個事吧一旦有人開始懷疑開始調查了那真的就是漏洞百出被良心譴責的數十名Cerenos的前員工就站出來指證鄧姐的罪行並提供了證據
鄧姐很快也發現了華爾街日報正在調查她那作為21世紀最厲害的女企業家她自然也不甘示弱她的那個魔鬼律師就開始去威脅所有的前員工你不能跟華爾街日報說一個字你別忘了咱們可簽過協議你可不想身敗名裂鄧姐甚至還僱了私人偵探去跟蹤所有可疑的前員工
又找到了之前給他投1.25億美金的媒體大佬莫多克。為啥？因為華爾街日報不就是他們家的嗎？好在這回莫多克還是非常的理性的，他相信這個華爾街日報的人不會胡說八道，於是他就跟鄧姐說，啊，好孩子，清者自清，你不用擔心。殊不知這時候鄧姐心裡最擔心的就是清者自清啊。
2015年10月15日，《華爾街日報》發表了文章，有理有據地指出了Theranos公司的謊言。那個所謂的愛迪生神奇機器其實就是個擺設，什麼也測不出來，根本就測不準。此文一出，輿論嘩然。於是他只能選擇孤注一擲，放大招去蠱惑大眾。他找到了CNBC的著名節目《Mad Money》。這就是在你努力去改變事情時發生的事情。首先他們覺得你瘋狂，然後他們對你爭執，然後你突然間改變了世界。
言外之意就是說清者自清我在做一件偉大的事情咱們走著瞧吧之後接受華爾街日報採訪的時候鄧姐還是一臉無辜瞪著她的大眼睛眼都不帶眨一下的睜著眼說瞎話我們提供的測試都是最高質量我們從來沒有吸食過血液我們從來沒有用過第三方的檢測機器我們要改變事不過這回大眾也不吃這套了
新聞剛報出來不久，隨著被誤診的人越來越多，FDA就緊急叫停了在Walgreens藥房裡所有的職監抽血測試。藥監局CMS突襲檢查了Theranos,撤銷了他的實驗室執照。投資人們也開始一個一個的把Theranos告上法庭。2018年Theranos解散，美國證監會SEC禁止鄧姐在10年內擔任美國上市公司的高管，並且交了50萬美金的罰款。
當然這只是證監會的懲罰鄧姐還有她的首席運營官Sunny還將面臨著多達11項罪名指控和最高20年的監禁這個Sunny其實很重要她是鄧姐的投行幫兇也是鄧姐的前男友而時間關係這老哥我們今天沒再多提鄧姐的審判原定在7月13號進行但是因為她在7月份剛生了孩子於是這項審判被推到了8月31日開始審理
鄧姐瞪眼說瞎話這個蠱惑的力量真的是太強大了家人董事會客戶媒體大眾都對她深信不疑要不是那些硬梆梆的事實和實打實的數據就擺在我們面前真的很難相信這個滿眼真誠的女人嘴裡竟然沒有一句真話其實有很多跟她非常親近的家人和同事都表示鄧姐真的可能是覺得她在做一件非常偉大的事情她真心覺得她又能幫助全人類改變世界
只不過在通完偉大的道路上你多多少少可能會有一些小挫折小謊言小誇大這些也都是不可避免直到今天鄧姐也從來沒有承認過自己的錯誤也沒有向任何人道過歉
這就是鄧姐的童話一滴血的童話一滴血可以改變世界的童話她用嬌媚的外表略帶天才色彩的人設大膽的騙術和幾乎可以穿透你靈魂的眼神讓你相信這個童話而這個童話真正的成本卻是成千上萬無辜人的健康和生命
聽力測試現在開始。